fox news contributor sarah carter is
back with us okay sarah so this is an
issue that you've been following very
closely over the past year and that's
the humanitarian crisis that's been
unfolding on our southern border which
has been one of biden's worst policy
failures of 2021. by march customs and
border patrol had already encountered
roughly
172 000 migrants at the border the
highest number in years the number kept
ballooning month over month and in total
border patrol sold more than 1.7 million
encounters in fiscal year 2021 that's
the highest ever on record
we saw president biden appoint kamala
harris as a quasi-border czar to deal
with the root causes of the immigration
crisis that they brought about with
their own messaging
i would in fact make sure that there is
we immediately surged to the border
she took a trip to central america and
accomplished absolutely nothing then she
went down to the border in el paso texas
more than 700 miles away from where the
real crisis was occurring and again
accomplished nothing
then about a month ago a federal judge
ordered the biden administration to
reinstate trump's remaining mexico
policy because things have gotten so bad
you might think that's a step in the
right direction but never underestimate
joe biden's ability to screw things up
they're now asking the supreme court to
rule on the issue in an effort to end
the remain in mexico policy once and for
all you know sarah you've been following
this maybe closer than anyone you know
what do you expect for for this new year
i'm actually very concerned i was in
guatemala i interviewed president yamate
of guatemala while
vice president kamala harris was there
it was a complete failure her trip fell
apart completely and the president of
guatemala made that very clear i spent
the last year you know lisa on the
border actually in del rio in the rio
grande valley in arizona and i saw the
surge i got to tell you this we keep
saying it's abide in policy failure it's
a failure for the american people for
our national security it's a
humanitarian crisis and a failure for
those being trafficked across the border
but i actually believe based on what
president biden and his administration
is doing this is what they want this is
actually part of their policy their
policy is to just open the floodgates
and allow people to come in i've spoken
with immigration and customs enforcement
officers i've been talking to border
patrol agents i've talked to law
enforcement officials along the border
and they're stunned they can't do their
jobs whether that's title 42 they remain
in mexico which they say they're not
even implementing now because they're
not even being allowed they can't even
make these arrests they're just
releasing people into the united states
in droves and let's talk about covid
there's no policy there they're allowing
people into the country if they're so
concerned about all the americans that
have covet or spreading cobit or want to
create all these mandates they have a
wide open border it's like a coveted
surge there if that's what they're
saying and they're not testing except
when necessary so we have an issue here
that is frankly i think at the highest
level of national security and it's
really really concerning and so for the
next year i think it's going to get far
worse particularly if they get their way
well and to that point i mean we had tom
homan the former acting director of ice
he recently said this
borbachos encounter people from 150
different countries 150 different
countries so the whole world knows our
borders open the whole world knows that
it gets our border than getting the
united states and many of these
countries you know either support or or
are sponsors of terrorism that should
scare people
it should scare me you had mentioned
yeah talk about that
yeah tom holman is 100 correct we've
seen people come across the border this
is based on information that border
patrol has released from yemen that has
been connected uh and possibly connected
to terror organizations there was a
gentleman from saudi arabia possibly
connected to terror organizations and i
want you to think about all the people
that have not been apprehended all the
people that are godaways and that's very
important for the american people to
understand the apprehensions are usually
the people that the traffickers want the
border patrol to take into custody those
are the people they search through uh
the young undocumented children the
family units but what about the people
they're trying to sneak in while they're
pushing people in one direction they're
sending narcotics they're sending people
that don't want to be apprehended those
are people with criminal records or
possibly people with terror ties or
possibly people on the interpol database
list these are issues that the biden
administration just does not want to
answer which is why they clam up every
time they're asked a question i know
peter ducey's held them accountable many
times at white house press conferences
and they refuse to answer these
questions because they know what i am
saying what the border patrol agents are
saying what the ice officers are saying
is 100 correct and they don't have an
answer for it and i'm really afraid that
if something happens it could be a
catastrophe for our national security
and for the american people and just
and just to give perspective i mean look
at this yuma sector border encounters
you look at october november of 2020
1777 and then october november of 2021
44
512 yet somehow the byte administration
is trying to say there's there's nothing
to see here you know real quick like 15
seconds before we've got to go
well the numbers are the facts facts
don't have feelings we know what's
happening at the border and we've got to
see there's still thousands more getting
ready to head here from mexico and from
central america and from more than 150
countries across the globe
sarah carty thanks for joining us hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else